هل فقط في رمضان نتذكر فعل الخير ابدا
دائما نسعى الى الخير في كل الاوقات
وخصوصا في رمضان
[موسيقى]
المكان لان احنا غاديين اللي في مناطق
جبليه واعره وصعبه المنال اخذنا الطريق في
اتجاه لاول مره نذهب اليه
[موسيقى]
طبيعه عملي بالمدينه طبيعه فيها ضغوطات في
التزامات فيها اشياء كثيره اقضي يومي بين
المواعيد والضغط والاوراق والادارات
والابناء رمضان هو فرصه اذا كانت لك رغبه
ان تبادر الى العطاء نحن مجموعه من الشباب
فكرنا انشاء مؤسسه
للعمل خيري جمعيه ديالنا كنديروا الحفر
ترميم المساجد كذلك العينين بالايتام
كمساعده المعوذين
هذه مؤسسه حديثه الولاده هذه مبادره
الثالثه في رمضان لكن هذه المره سنرفع
التحدي ونصعد جبال الاطلس
[موسيقى]
اخذنا الطريق في اتجاه لاول مره نذهب اليه
المكان اللي احنا غادي نلف مناطق جبليه
وعره وصعدت المنال
كانت الطريق جبليه وصعبه لكنها ممتعه
رائعه خلابه
[موسيقى]
وصراحه كانت فرصه لاكتشاف مناطق لم نعرفها
من قبل مناظر تجعلك تستمتع وانك تتجاوز
تلك العقبات وتلك المنعرجات وتلك الطرق
[موسيقى]
سفر في الجبال صعب تعرضنا للكثير من
المفاجات واول هذه الاشياء ادركنا الفطار
في الطريق رغم ان كنا مخططين ان نصل على
عصر اذا بنا نتفاجا بمنعرجات وان الشاحنه
المحمله بالمواد الغذائيه ومصاحف كانت
يصعب علي التمشي بسرعه وسط منعرجات وطرق
لكن احد سكان الجبال عزمنا على الفطار رغم
اننا لا نعرف ولا يعرفنا وهذا ليس غريب
على المغاربه
والمفاجاه الثانيه ان تعرضنا الى عطب في
عجله السياره
هما دعى استدعنه ان نغيره في ظلام الليل
الداكن وسط الجبال
بعد عشر ساعات من الطريق وصلنا الى القريه
فوجدنا اناس بطريقه استرحاب رائعه انستنا
كل
[موسيقى]
بعد استيقاظنا في الصباح الباكر وخروجنا
من البيت وجدنا طبيعه اقول لك خياليه
رائعه جدا
[موسيقى]
بدانا قافلتنا بتوزيع مصاحف القران على
اطفال القريه بالمسجد كانت فرحتهم رائعه
[موسيقى]
وبعدها بدانا بتوزيع قصص رمضاني على على
سكان القريه
في هذه القافله
جهزنا مئه قفه و200 مصحف للتوزيع في هذه
القريه وهدفنا ان نوزع الالاف من القفه في
المبادرات القادمين ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
رغم بساطه هذه المؤونه الا ان رمزيتها
عظيمه في نفوس هؤلاء الناس وهذا ما نسعى
اليه هو ان نشارك اناس بسطاء فرحته
ورمضانهم يعني صراحه السعاده في العطاء
وليس في
مدهش المنظر والبيوت وسط الجبال سكن هؤلاء
الناس في الجبال وحتى زراعه في الجبال
كم نحن صغارا امام الطبيعه اخرج سافر غامر
اكتشف التطور في العمل الخيري وهو فرصه
للخروج من منطقه الراحه من ضغوطات من
الجدران التي يحاصرك من ذلك الانان
المحدود من المدينه نحو فضاء اوسع نحو
ثقافات اخرى واناس اخرين رمضان فرصه من
اجل التغيير
[موسيقى]